good morning Hank it's Monday December
18 2012 which means it's time for the
sixth annual project for awesome so all
over YouTube today people are making
videos about their favorite nonprofit
organization and right now you can go to
project for awesome calm and submit your
videos and also vote for your favorites
to help decide where the project for
awesome funds go and speaking of those
funds they only exist if you donate
there's a project for awesome IndieGoGo
page with amazing rewards including the
men of YouTube calendar featuring Hank
and me in togas don't my god Hank how
did you talk me into that also for the
next 48 hours there will be a livestream
at the vlogbrothers YouTube channel and
we'll be commenting and sharing and
liking videos generally making the
internet about charity for a couple days
and then after that we'll return to
discussing the Debra Lee dress monkeys
of canada's ikea parking lots so like
let's talk about poverty to which you
and i have a long-standing and public
opposition there are about 1.4 billion
people who live in what is called
absolute poverty which means they
survive on less than a dollar 25 a day
and have inadequate resources to get
food water and shelter and before you
say that a dollar goes a lot further in
zambia than it does in the united states
that calculation isn't based on exchange
rates it's based on what's called
purchasing power parity so when we talk
about people living on a dollar 25 a day
we mean that they live on what i can buy
here in the US for a dollar and 25 cents
i think poverty is an incredibly complex
problem corrupt governments worse than
poverty as do diseases like malaria and
hiv/aids that not only kill people but
also make them too sick to work
everything from climate change to energy
policy can hurt food production which
increases prices and thus malnutrition
lack of infrastructure poor educational
systems discrimination all of these
things contribute to poverty Hank as my
college girlfriend once said when I
asked her if she still loved me it's
complicated and that's why I love saved
the children Hank in 2009 the
nerdfighter community worked with Sean's
uncultured project and saved the
children to build a pond sand filter for
a village in Bangladesh so they could
have access to clean water but that's
just one kind of thing they do poverty
is complex and Save the Children
responds to it complexly they train
teachers they keep kids healthy through
hiv-aids work that focuses on those
orphaned by the disease they train
farmers and how to deal with droughts
they respond to natural disasters and
they train and employ midwives and other
frontline health professionals to offer
good prenatal care and keep kids healthy
but 7 million kids under the age of 5
are going to die this year and most of
them will die of diseases that can be
treated or prevented inexpensively Hank
those kids aren't fundamentally
different from my son who by the way
painted this he's - he's a genie
they aren't other just because they were
born into poverty they can live full and
long lives and help make the world a
better and more interesting place for
all of us they can be construction
workers and accountants and beauty gurus
and vloggers but first they have to
survive to the age of five when we cut
childhood illness and death rates we
also cut poverty rates and Hank Save the
Children does this with astonishing
efficiency 91% of donations go not to
fundraising efforts or overhead but
directly to programs plus they work
around the world from Pakistan to the
United States to Australia to Angola so
for this year's project for awesome I am
supporting Save the Children so the last
two years I've sold bad zombie stories
to raise money during the project for
awesome this year I'm changing tack by
sharing an e-book containing stories I
hope aren't bad
including a semi autobiographical story
called double on-call which was the
first thing I ever wrote on the very
long road to writing The Fault in Our
Stars you can only get it by
contributing to the project for awesome
and remember since we have no overhead
100% of donations through the foundation
to decrease worldsuck go to project for
awesome charities which charities well
that's partly up to you so head over to
projectforawesome.com watch the
livestream here at the vlogbrothers
channel and remember every comment you
make on a project for awesome video is a
penny that I have to donate to charity
so comment like crazy dftba Hank I will
see you on the livestream